[Music]
hey kevin o'leary aka mr wonderful where
am i in los angeles why we're shooting
shark tank in the middle of it we have a
dark day we have a day off
where do i want to be when i'm in los
angeles on a dark day
inside of the fp journey boutique why
because i love this brand i love this
watch and i happen to be with teddy
because we're doing a bunch of social
media and watches and teddy's never
really seen a broad collection of fp
jordans like he's going to see today so
i'm his host along with a legend here
too the brother of fb joining himself
and he's looking very la today which is
fantastic what i'd like to do is tell
you a little story about this brand now
watch collecting is about the love of
art it's also about the love of
investing because you want to find
pieces of art you want to find watches
that are unique and different and i'm
all about the dial and there's no dial
on earth like one made by fp jordan
that's why this brand has rocketed in
the last 17 years to practice the top of
the echelon of
i call it micro brands but really
something else now because collectors
all around the world really really
try and find these pieces for themselves
in the secondary market but also
directly from jordan himself they only
make about 900 pieces a year that's it
and that's why it's very hard to get one
of these however when you talk about
investing my goodness the appreciation
is insane
let me ask you lauren why it's been the
last five years this brand has gone
crazy why why
i guess people start
getting
tired of massive production they want
exclusivity rarity
yeah well you get that for sure
but also these pieces
are all different they all have their
own personalities the the movements the
calibers are unique
they're kind of pieces of art that's the
way i look at it
that's what they are
yeah because nobody needs a watch today
yeah no one needs a watch
you have two three cell phones maybe
yeah why do you want to buy a watch
i have way more than that and watches
but because i know i'm talking about the
cell phones oh i see yeah yeah but you
know fp journey i like to call it a
disease
because when you buy one you get
infected and it's very bad economically
for you
that i don't know for you yeah but uh
yeah unfortunately there's no vaccine
it's very it's very
unusual that
our collectors
only buy one fp
they want them all
now at the moment it's virtually
impossible we try to please as many
people as we can
but we disappoint a lot we have to ask
them to be patient
yeah i i've been through that journey
myself i have to be patient but
i have to ask a question i mean i have
the opportunity to speak to somebody so
connected to friends friends about paul
i mean talk about getting into his head
and what he creates in these watches and
because i think that's part of the entry
he talked about art these are all i
think parts of his own creation what
he's going after could you talk about
just his general philosophy when he
makes a piece do you know him so
personally
well he
he wants to create he wants to be
honest
with
his characters always
um
it's difficult to talk about francois
ball
on a personal level he's he's he's
always thinking about something if you
ask him that's the perfect example that
will probably answer your question
if you ask him what is your favorite
watch fp juan watch
and he will he will tell you the next
one
so that's something that i can resume
like this i think
he will tell you the next one that's
something he always think about
innovation
so for him uh doing 10 times the same
thing is too boring the reason i got
into jordan was the people that were the
collectors
that is the craziest group of people
i've ever met from every walk of life
every discipline you name it with one
consistent element to it their love of
joy and they're passionate about their
pieces and we love to talk about it
together now i have that disease too and
you're right there's no vaccine so i'm
constantly looking for my next short you
know i'm waiting patiently i'm always
bugging everybody
but it's it's a fantastic journey
because
let me be pragmatic about the
perspective yes they're expensive
but they're great value as an investment
but if you consider what is in any of
the species that we are here yes
value for money
i would agree with you i would agree
with you these are extraordinary pieces
and you know
the one that
i wanted the most when i first met fp in
new york and the people at the new york
boutique was this piece santigraft tokyo
yeah beautiful
it's it's um
one of the ten that were made for the
new york boutique correct
um
i always said i would like to buy it
they laughed at me
they laughed at me because there was a
thousand people trying to buy this piece
and it would only go
to a collector
who had at least
three journals
well
obviously we want to
please our
oldest collector
but we need
new blood as well
in the in the company let me tell you
what i did to get this watch
well i i i basically you know in talking
with pierre he said look kevin you don't
even own a journey why don't you start
small buy one and i'll get you we always
ask for this and i said but how can i
get this piece he said
you don't even have one you need three
at least i said i'll buy four
which i've never done before ever with
any brand
what i did that day i actually sat down
with him and i
built a collection over a 24-hour period
and i bought them all that's the most
i've ever spent at once in any brand and
i'm so glad i did because every one of
these watches has been an incredible
investment
and now when i walk around with this
piece
everybody goes nuts that knows jordan
absolutely nuts so teddy hold that for a
second one of ten
extremely coveted within the gerund
society but
you know i was on a flight to geneva
from new york to visit my father with
this piece on and the woman beside me in
the line getting on the plane said
how the hell can you even tell the time
on that thing i said i don't
i've heard that story before yeah
because it's art she said that's crazy
who made that watch
that tells you it's a great watch it
starts a conversation
that's what makes it so magic and of
course it has elements of red which for
me are very important all my watches
have red bands
let's talk a little bit
on about some of these pieces you've
been kind enough to show us some of
yours what about this tell us tell us
the history of this chronometer optimum
that's the watch that francois paul
initially wanted to create i mean for
those who
may not know
the first watch wristwatch that once
what paul made was the torbjorn then he
wanted to make the
most
accurate mechanical wristwatch possible
after the tourbillon
because the tourbillon doesn't mean that
it's an accurate watch right what's
going to make the accuracy of the watch
will be the constant force or motor
the tourbillon is a parasite for the
watch it's heavy to carry it's nice to
look at but other than that is useless
so i wanted to make this and this watch
came only in 2012
because he couldn't make it he couldn't
put all the elements together
so to reach this accuracy
the optimum
is made with four exceptional elements
the first one
are the two barrels mounted in parallel
not to increase the power reserve
remember we are looking for accuracy
so because the
dual barrel mounted in parallel will
deliver a more stable energy to the
escapement
before the escapement we got a constant
force from antoine which is going to
deliver the energy to the escapement the
energy from the barrels to the
escapement at the moment where the
second passes
it generates like in the tourbillon a
natural deadbeat circle
that is shown at the back of the watch
if you want to there's the deadbeat
yes and
francois paul wanted to show it because
it's generated by the constant force or
montoya but by putting it on the on the
dial then the diol would have been
unbalanced
and this is the last thing he wants this
is gold is it not yes this one is good
yeah so he's maximizing the torque of
that mainstream um with that remnant
the the constant force for montoya is a
complicated chain of wheel
[Music]
that talks to the escapement
so the just to finish with the elements
the third element is the high
performance by actual escapement
what is the enemy
of
accuracy in a mechanical wristwatch
friction
so
to limit the friction
what do you need every weekend yeah but
with the time lubricant
becomes a problem gets dry gets
within 10 years right
it depends now the oil are synthetic
they are good qualities
but if you can avoid lubricant it's like
in your car
you don't need to change the oil yeah
this watch not
talking about the whole watch but the
escapement of this watch works with no
oil at all so no no swiss leverage no no
no no lubricant at the escapement there
is all in other parts but which is
the
the escapement is the biggest consumer
of
oil into into the system the reason is
it's a bi-actual
so it's simple to understand like this
if you press hard with your hand
on the
surface well if you want to move
you need oil
if you divide the friction by two
no more needle oil
so two escapement wheels on this one
no way
and the last element is the philips
curve termination on the balance wheel
for a better equilibrium
and that makes
all that together
a masterpiece
is this the most accurate of the journey
watches they are all accurate but
this one is extreme yeah fantastic i'm
very proud to own this with a black dial
on it which is amazing
beautiful watch yesterday yes thank you
let's talk about this story um last
night
i we had a guest uh come to the set of
shark tank his name is peter jones and
he's a legend in england where he's been
on the dragonstone show which is the
equivalent in england for 18 years one
of the longest running shows on the
planet
and we were having dinner to get to know
each other and i noticed on his wrist
at derby on an fp journey tourbillon he
said you know what you have there he
said yeah i do my wife bought it for me
in harrods it's a very famous department
store
17 years ago
and i told him i was coming to meet you
here today that we would come to the
jordan boutique we're going to do this
with you teddy talking about fp journey
and he said take it with you
i would love to have them see it because
it hasn't been an adjourned boutique for
17 years it's going home
and
you confirmed this
it's been made in 2004
what's this watch worth today it was a
gift from his wife who bought it because
she loved the dial
she probably didn't know a lot about
jordan at the time
bought it for him he loved it when he
got it this is made of platinum waste of
time correct it's got to be platinum so
heavy yeah
it's a lot of platinum there yeah
well it started it started with the
subscription the tourbillon that was the
first one
because once what paul didn't have money
enough
to produce the watches so the people who
are paying in advance and one watch when
it was sold to the to the owner
one watch was financing the other one
i guess in the early so this is one of
the early days no this one is not a
subscription this one is a so
this one is a is a tn
that came after the t
the reason why
i mean the difference between the t the
main one because i don't want to get
into too much details is that the t
didn't have the dead second
ah
so it was just this is the dead circle
like this yes it was just showing the
constant force
not the second yeah and francois paul
was looking at the wall she said well
the constant force hormone as i
mentioned earlier
generates a natural
natural deadbeat circuit
it's stupid not to show it
so that's when he came with the tn
because the generation after the tea
with the deadbeat second and now if you
want to buy a platinum tn
it's in well you can buy it secondhand
yeah we don't know what do you think it
would trade for
it depends on the condition conditions
the speeches
yeah absolutely it's it's in great
conditions i would say
300k
minimum 300 thousand dollars
what a great investment that wife made
and absolutely
and this combination is pretty rare with
the uh gold dial yeah normally they come
in a great idea
how about that
i'm gonna tell
so actually it could be a little bit
more really more than 300 yeah he's good
now that before that was produced yes
you know what i love about him and i
only met him yesterday he wears his
watches well that's the whole idea yeah
he wears his watches he's wearing this
piece and when it comes to the shark
tank set
i mean it gives it a soul it makes it
real even though this thing is so rare
and it's you know a beautiful investment
and they are not fragile
yeah it's a beautiful piece
you know
i loved it you know i looked at it and
said oh my goodness that's that's it's a
piece of legend
now let's see some behind your back
yeah i've got something rare here i
heard rumor of this piece okay
uh this is it was an idea
fp had to create 18 complications in a
watch which is impossible for the first
place and then have them all adjustable
from one crown which is not only
impossible it's insane it could never be
done
but
here it is
it was done tell us about this watch
this is the rarest of the rare
uh built for individuals correct
astronomique
18 complications all controlled
truly
how is that even possible
you know francois
i mean how long did it take to even
think this six years
eight years
yep
incredible
and the design
of the dial
came from a
drawing that
charles son
one of his son
made
years ago
and francois paul inspires himself from
this drawing
to make that
not for the movement obviously
so this is uh
the crown jewel of fp
for now yes it is yeah for now so that
was the next one remember yeah but
if a collector wants to buy this watch
how much is it i mean to order one
the collector has to be approved by
francois paul so he needs first of all
to fill up an application yeah from the
moment the application is approved the
gentleman will have to pay 50
of the price of the watch which is which
is
in swiss franc 885 000 swiss franc
close to a million dollars u.s close to
a million dollars u.s 960 last time i
checked yeah so you put down 500 000 usd
kind of and then how long does it take
to make the watch well it depends uh
to make the watch it's three and a half
to four months
but we got lots of requests already on
this as well and then there is a waiting
list for this as well
as crazy as you can see how many per
year are going to be made three three
right yeah
drink retreat
so this is truly a collector's piece
there's no question
because
you know but
it's a beautiful watch it has the
classic elements and probably you have
to sit down for a couple of hours to
figure out how to set it it's going to
take a while to learn it's not that
complicated really no
the
the user user manual
is one
one piece of paper
that's it but you know i notice also the
watch is also on the back it's not just
seeing the movement
of time there's information on the
background
there are a lot of information at the
back a question of time you can see the
tourbillon you can see the annual
calendar with the zodiac or
zodiac sign
what else do you see there
so on the face you got so you have the
power reserve
okay
two time zones here
local time zone on the gold hand and
second time zone there sunrise sunset
here are the seconds that are jumping
seconds
due to the constant force for montour
again
several time
and minutes
so
that's it for it i love the sunrise
sunset indicator that is beautiful and
the window gets narrower such a cool
execution of that in the back and then
the back you have here
the equation of time
you can see the tourbillon here
and as i said the
annual calendar and if you activate this
this is the sharing of the cake
minute repeater
stainless steel
yes yeah for the sound
we got an option in gold now oh yeah
really rose gold yeah must be beautiful
it's gorgeous yeah
different sound i assume
no not not really
and the other complication that doesn't
show on the watch itself as
indication so we got the
tourbillon
constant force from antoine
and durbar all mounted in parallel as
well
fantastic
it's truly a piece of art yes it is i
mean so we've had a very special day
today here you know bjorn because it's
so rare to get all these watches
including one that's 17 years old
all in the same place at the same time
and
noth nothing better than to have fp's
brother here laurent explaining this to
us for collectors now probably one of
the
most sought after brands in the world
it's it's going through a transition
you have to remember one thing about
this brand
fp jordan's still alive
he's still alive he is the picasso of
watchmakers and he still walks the earth
so that in itself is remarkable a lot of
the designers of some of the most famous
pieces are no longer with us
he's still here still designing new ones
i've had a fantastic journey teddy thank
you very much laurent spectacular kevin
thank you everybody so much thank you
pleasure hit that like button and listen
subscribe because we're going to have a
lot of fun we're going to do this again
somewhere and i can't wait for my turbo
i've been waiting i'm on the waiting
list i'm waiting fp please listen to me
get me that watch i'm dying for it
thanks everybody take care